for Commodities it seems that All That
Glitters Is Gold amid recent turmoil in
the financial system and concerns over
the health of the global economy gold
has remained stable here's why the
precious metal is continuing to shine
investors piled into gold in March the
price is currently hovering at just
under two thousand dollars an ounce and
it has risen 8.4 this year the recent
rise comes after the collapse of Silicon
Valley Bank and Signature Bank in the US
and the Takeover of Swiss Bank Credit
Suisse by its rival UBS a late March
sell-off in Germany's Deutsche Bank has
also ramped up concerns about the
financial system but yet gold has
sparkled through the chaos in investors
value gold for its stability during
uncertain times and often look to the
precious metal as an alternative to the
traditional banking system here's one
example of its recent appeal in the week
following the svb collapse net inflows
into gold exchange traded funds stood at
roughly 14 tons that's over 1 billion
dollars worth for a couple of months
before the collapse investors had been
pulling money out of funds in March gold
benefited from expectations That central
banks would reduce the speed of interest
rate hikes in order to cut pressure on
the financial system over the last year
the Federal Reserve has raised interest
rates in a bid to tame inflation these
hikes made goal less attractive for
investors because unlike other
Investments the metal does not pay
interest
in March Fed chair Jerome Powell
announced yet another rate rise but he
hinted that it could be the last one for
now leading to a jump in gold prices we
no longer state that we anticipate that
ongoing rate increases will be
appropriate to coil inflation gold is
also getting a boost from a decline in
the dollar a weaker dollar lifts the
price of Commodities that are backed by
the US currency one of which is gold
to compare gold had a more lackluster
year in 2022
it was briefly trading at about two
thousand dollars an ounce following
Russia's invasion of Ukraine however as
the FED began lifting its rates to curb
inflation the dollar soared to a 20-year
High which led to a slight climb down in
gold prices but the US dollar has since
retreated from its 2022 Peak which has
enabled gold prices to bounce back
towards the end of March gold prices
Rose towards its record level before
dropping down slightly that's as rescue
measures for struggling Banks helped
ease contagion fears however analysts
expect gold to remain resilient it has
been performing strongly remaining above
1500 an ounce for the last three years
according to the world gold Council
analysts at Fitch Solutions believe that
mounting Global Financial instability is
likely to keep on driving up gold prices
solidifying's reputation as a safe haven
asset